[Music]
you know
okay welcome back to the true Geordie
podcast today's guest is now a second
time it's Ali dawa welcome back brother
thank you very much it's a pleasure to
be here if you're a million subscribers
now you've been doing big things you've
just made your own documentary about
finding a wife in Islam seeing that I
thought be a great uh chat because I
have been going down a bit of uh
interesting line of guests recently
talking about relationships and uh
modern dating versus traditional dating
and you're definitely coming into that
chat with your own point of view and
also I do want to say thanks for coming
on last time because I was going through
a difficult time and you uh extending
the olive branch and your subscribers
also sending me a lot of positivity it
showed me
um you know in the midst of my mistake
and everything I was going through a
really positive side of Islam and and
it's great to have you back on
um the documentary immediately uh you're
into your life prior to finding Islam
and you went through Allah before
fighting in Islam like that was uh you
know serious gangs you were involved in
by the looks of it you had a full-blown
relationship with a woman you were
cheating on her you were doing
everything the wrong way yes so yeah
what was that all like um so I came to
this time about 10 years ago and before
that you just typical lad you know I was
involved with individuals Etc fighting
and all that kind of stuff my dad saw me
getting into trouble not listening to my
mom uh once I was walking down wood
green had a knuckle duster and the
undercover officers arrested me so my
dad said look you're coming because he
had a business up north so he took me
there my life changed from that to
partying clubbing girls holidays got
into a relationship which lasted about
four to five years uh did some really
bad stuff that I regret and yeah after
that I moved to London started
University here and I just wanted to
find myself and be my true self because
I realized I was living for others I was
enslaved to pleasing other people so
that's when I looked into Islam and
different variety of religions and I
came to the conclusion that Islam is the
one that's from God my dad hates Islam
with a passion
um he would say the thing that I hate
the most has been born into my family so
there was times when I was kicked out
um and by the way I don't seem to vidify
my father it's just there's things that
he's seen that he was treated in a
certain way by Muslims in our country uh
back in Turkey
um so that yeah yeah that left them
great trauma even until this day like I
will show him certain evidences but he
he'll just be like look you can never
take away how I was made to feel okay
can we can we go into this because I
didn't go into this with you last night
but I remembered I remember hearing like
it stayed with me a lot of what you said
in that first podcast and I haven't
listened to it back I just remember
specifically you like almost shaking as
he caught you praying oh yeah and your
mother being like Oh God you know what
do we do yeah it really you painted the
picture so well I didn't realize he went
through issues uh in Turkey what what
kind of specifics did he feel were like
the things that stuck with him my family
they they are Alloy so alawits are
basically a set of shias that the shias
deemed them to be disbelievers
so they were persecuted in Turkey
although by the Sunni Muslims so for
example like you know being mocked at
you know argumentative my mum was not to
wear the hijab or you know if because of
the belief system there was actually
people that actually there was a
building that was set on fire on purpose
and many people died so that trauma has
yes done by suddenly Muslims sadly
misguided individuals that we even had
to date like well a couple of years ago
with the whole Isis and all that kind of
stuff too yeah so um that's left to
scarring so he he's just like I hate
these people they are terrible people
they've done nothing but bad to us so
that's left a scar with him it's rumor
so when I would look into Islam and
sometimes when I was a non-muslim I
would try fasting the moment he would he
would see me fasting he would lose it he
would lose it like it would give me food
if I was to say no he would go crazy
isn't it funny how as parents you see
whatever parents deemed to be the worst
possible thing yes their child often
will be drawn to that so like yes in
it's like it's a Joby thing but like in
Catholic families the daughters often
end up going off the deep end or what
like that's the stereotype rather yeah
this five-year relationship that you had
prior to
um you know leaving her and all of that
um you go to her house a very
interesting moment because you you go
there with the intention of apologizing
I wasn't sure what exactly you were
apologizing for I mean there's this
loyalty
um
did you find out about you cheating and
stuff yeah and and it it wasn't once to
be honest I didn't
to a certain level so there was a lot of
disloyalty there was um some even
classes psychological abuse do you mean
like she felt uh intimidated by you
you can see you can see like I was very
close with the family like for example
the family I was very close because when
I moved from London to there my mom
lived here so I didn't really have
anybody there she was like the second
mother to me so I was very close with
the family and um it was like not being
with it was the most frightening thing
ever like because there was attachment
there and I talked about it in uh my
early years in documentary for example
um approaching certain girls and not
getting the attention that I wanted that
built and a lot of men could relate it
that's the reason I mentioned it you
build this resentment that was that was
a really revealing part I thought that
was it was good to hear that as much as
sometimes a lot of people might not like
to hear that yes but it it's good to be
truthful and admit you know I didn't
feel um attractive to the opposite sex
and it made me resent them and yes even
you said you hated women yeah yeah I
mean before Islam you know trying to get
the attention not being given to you it
was very traumatic and there's a lot of
men that could relate to that it's like
to us as a man it's very very hard to
approach
and then the moment you do and you get
rejected it is quite daunting it is like
for a woman they wouldn't really
understand that because that's why we
say men and women are different because
from a young age they are born with
value we have to earn our value you know
so for them getting approach Left Right
Center walking down the street they are
they are being flocked I'm trying to say
and sought after so they don't really
understand what does rejection mean
because they are too busy rejecting
although I do think we often say in
society as well women who when they've
had their hearts broke and maybe one or
two times or they've been cheated on yes
they start building up a similar kind of
exactly and that's when they start
seeing things like all men are trash yes
and I understand from both sides like
how this can happen for a man it's
rejection that could have a trauma for a
woman it's being in a relationship and
being used but there's protocols in
place to protect your heart and her
heart and that's the reason I was just
reading an article uh official Carolyn
Carolyn Flack Caroline who committed
suicide yeah yes so the thing is when I
heard that and I read into it it was
because of these failed relationships
women look for security reassurance so
when she's in a relationship and that
person in a relationship is giving her
the impression that he's serious and he
comes and guess what he wants and leaves
how do you think that leaves a woman in
pieces shattered cannot trust men that's
the reason why men are trash why why are
men trash so it's always connected by
that and I'm not blaming just men
because there are a lot of women out
there who manipulate as well but the
point is do you see the traumas I want
to go back into the fact that you wanted
to reconnect with her and do this
apology because I definitely have I've
reached out to women from my past and
apologized okay as an older man and said
when they've contacted me they may have
sent me a nice message said see what's
happening with your YouTube
congratulations and I'm like oh my god
I've wanted to say sorry to you wow 10
plus years so I really did connect with
what you were doing but I did wonder
who was this apology for is it for you
to make you feel better or is it for her
or both or how did how did you and
overall how did you feel about that to
me look I could just say you know what
it was from a past as a Muslims we
believe if you've if you've committed
sins in the past you're forgiven
unless you've run someone people or you
owe debt those are serious matters you
can't say oh I've accepted this time now
I'm not going to pay you ten thousand
pounds no you have to so was it for me I
would say no because if it was for me I
would just say you know what message the
mom and say look I just want to say can
you pass this message onto your daughter
I am deeply sorry
case girls feel good about myself and
move on I believe that's selfish so I
said to myself no you have to take
yourself to account and now a lot of
people will think that in the
documentary it's just her
I wronged a lot of people I got into
dating again because at the end of the
day I I was not a Muslim I was looking
into Islam I was not a Muslim yeah and
my lifestyle that I was living
you know the the lives I was living I
was in double Minds about look I'm
sinning I should become perfect first
and a lot of people go through this let
me stop sinning then I'll accept Islam
so that was causing me to not accept
Islam because I was like I'm still
partying girls all this kind of stuff
there was a um girl that I met
and again I wasn't serious about her
I think um was really really attached to
me and I came to a conclusion where I
said you know what enough is enough
I hate this lifestyle I hate linking up
with girls I hated it I can I literally
hate it I just didn't want to do it so I
can remember like yesterday walking out
that shop going around the corner
calling her
and I said look I can't do this anymore
I want to accept Islam I want to change
my life
Ted you know what I want to do the same
I want to wear the hijab I want to
change that and and I don't think she'd
understood what I was trying to say I
was trying to say look I basically I'm
not really interested in you like that
and I just want to cut this all up this
was just nothing but just stiffling
and because of that I I wasn't serious
about her but she said she was down to
do it all with you yes but the thing is
I was not attached to her like do you
see the problem so I wasn't using the
Muslim card I'm going to be a Muslim
therefore no no I was saying if I did
like you in that way 100 let's go on it
together but I've never had that from
the beginning I can remember man
the way she cried I swear to God
it rings in my ears toward this very day
man is there a guilt there for what you
feel maybe you've LED them on of course
this is this is what haunts me till this
day because this is another human being
this is not a water bottle an inanimate
object this is a human being with
emotions a soul and to me
that is like to for me to look in the
mirror and be like you did that to them
traumatizing why is it that it haunts
you more than a normal man I do not want
anybody to say I am unhappy or I am like
this because of him I read that and I
really respect that because it's funny
because people have this image of me
online because of the way I can put
myself across if I'm talking about
different subjects and you're an
Entertainer so you understand like
sometimes you you turn the volume up and
you act a bit more aggressive but that's
a version of you for the camera but like
me for when I look back at my life I
think all I see when I look back at my
past is care generosity taking care of
people and then those mistakes like they
really do live with me as well and I
think a lot of people forgive themselves
too easily a lot of people they want to
make themselves like if you if
um if I were if our life story is a
movie they view themselves as always the
good guy yes and any bad thing they do
yes they they excuse themselves of and
every good thing they do is all their
fault yes but the bad thing is never
their fault I think we have to take
accountability on both sides and I think
that more men especially should be doing
this sort of thing and that's the reason
why in episode one and two I had to tell
people how not to start their marriage
exactly well one interesting thing you
dropped in before was in regards to I
need to be perfect before I join Islam
and a friend of mine who I worked with
before uh shouts to a big Zoo uh who's a
well-known presenter and a a Muslim he
said like he put a tweet out saying why
do people expect Muslims to be more
perfect yes or their religions why why
you know and why why are we supposed to
be just held at this unattainable
standard all the time like you can be in
Islam and and not necessarily follow
every rule yes it doesn't make you not a
Muslim you know and I thought that was a
really good point because I think
there's some truth in that the way
people view I mean the way you clearly
did Once Upon a Time yeah so what was
that struggle like mentally and how did
you overcome it yeah so the thing is a
lot of people go through this so
anybody's like on the verge of accepting
Islam or any other religion for that
matter they think I have to stop sinning
then I would accept or Embrace this
religion it's a common we call it we
call it that it's The Whispers of Satan
just tell you oh you know you're not
perfect yet you know wait till you're
perfect God doesn't want us to be
perfect but it doesn't want us to be
perfect there's a Hadith of the Prophet
Muhammad the saying of the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him if mankind
was not to sin God Almighty will destroy
all of them and bring forth another
nation that sins but repents now what's
the key here is the key that God
Almighty wants you to sin no he knows
that you would sin he knows that you
would sin all he wants you to do is
acknowledge he exists and turn to him in
Repentance even if it's a million times
you commit the same sin you turn back to
him in Repentance
so to me it was the same thing I came to
the realization I said to myself for me
to change for the better I have to
accept Islam not Vice Versa oh let me
stop sinning no you stop you accept
Islam you start practicing and
eventually you would stop this sin it
doesn't work the other way around we
think it works the other way around so
you've got on the one hand you've got
people who were who were genuinely
wanting to join this religion and are
pure of heart if even if they are making
mistakes they are then going to be some
people I assume and you can tell me if
I'm wrong who who pick and choose what
they want from Islam and they have no
intention of ever being as perfect as
they can be and maybe it suits parts of
their life to say I don't know let's say
they're a husband and they want and you
know it's all right the rules for offer
the wife yeah but not for him yes you
know do you do you do you look at people
and have a little bit of uh Judgment of
them and go you know you're actually
just playing around here and you're not
really yeah what I classes are true
Muslim so now there's a balance to that
because Allah says in the Quran that
there are people who pick certain verses
and then there's actually verse like
that says that these picture in verses
Etc Islam doesn't work like that so but
what we can't do is also at the same
time judge because there's certain
things
people would look and be like hmm that
looks fishy plausible but we have to
give we have something called in Islam
assuming the best
so for example the early predecessor
predecessors of the companion would say
the following that if we saw somebody
drenched in alcohol
we'll say somebody supported over his
head okay so the thing is the Assumption
good assumption assume the best to an
extent you're not going to be a fool of
course you know that's against human
nature of course exactly it's very
cynical and that's the issue like we
have to make sure there's a balance and
those who we see that are transgressing
because there are a lot of people coming
to Islam now it's the fastest growing
religion it is now the thing is is a
trend I don't know we can come and say
you know what there's these people
they're just doing it just for the faith
maybe but there's a certain point where
we as Muslims would take it then we will
say well hold on a second my friend
you've come to Islam but you're still
doing this you're still doing that now
you're going to be put on the spotlight
you have to fix these things so new
Muslims we give them some time uh as
soon as American guy a white gentleman
who um who was doing videos back and
forward with you and oh yeah yeah and I
don't know if I'm supposed to ask this
but I want to ask all of the questions
please please
um when it comes to white people who are
like westernized joining Islam yeah how
how is that received to be honest they
are uh held a high steam like they're
like this is somebody in the west you
know when they come to Islam it's like
oh my gosh like this person has left
that lifestyle for Islam it means a lot
because a lot of Muslim have loved
inferiority complex so um when they see
that they're like oh my gosh they look
up to them so that's how they are seen
like a new Muslim they say me per se
like yes I'm I came to Islam but I have
that typical a look you know it was
trying to say so with them with the blue
eyes blonde hair that's why you will see
a lot of them who do reaction videos
they pop off okay hundreds of thousands
of views yeah when you see like a white
man blonde hair blue eyes or a woman
they do a video about Islam or I I like
this Quran recitation whoa fly it's
skyrockets so they they really really
treat them specially wow okay yeah
currently in in the UK we're seeing
what's being called a mate in crisis
where we've got less and less people
under the age of 30 settling down
getting married and a lot of people are
equating this to a lot of different
reasons but they're the general
consensus seems to be that we're moving
away from Traditional Values traditional
marriage and all that women are changing
more so than anything because women's
incomes are changing they're now earning
as much as men the Dynamics are
completely different and uh and internet
dating and all of these new things are
just taking over so I wondered what it
was like for uh traditional Muslims who
are looking to settle down are they also
seeing a decrease in that is it becoming
later and later and life is it becoming
harder what are you saying um as an
orthodox Muslim it's totally different
so like I said before it's these
Traditional Values that have been
abundant that is causing this and we
even see it in the Muslim Community it's
affecting us I mean like feminism even
red pill these are you know sneaking in
uh into our lifestyles and it's having a
dramatic impact in what way would you
see in many ways like for example very
clearly for example that a woman like in
Islam and a man like a man's duty is
that he's the provider and protector of
period and the woman has to be obedient
now this word will be like a feminist
might be watching this and ripping their
hair out obedience to the husband what
this is where I would tell you why Islam
is why there's so many women except in
Istanbul for every
five reverse three are women they say 60
to 70 are a woman wow so the thing is
it's like well this doesn't make sense
because we're seeing as you know
misogynistic and you know we just locked
our wives in the houses you know we have
a stick we you know every Friday we beat
her up yeah so there's these things in
people's minds but Islam has come to
protect the rights of the woman as well
that's one of the reasons you know if I
am looking to get to know somebody for
marriage
the first thing that I would do is
number one obviously approach and say
look here's my intentions don't do this
girlfriend boyfriend thing there's no
dating there's no sex before marriage
after I ask some basic simple questions
let's see I met somebody and I said look
here's my intention she goes okay I have
a liking too okay
um simple questions okay you know
argument's sake do you want to work
after we get married how many kids you
want okay good I would like to speak to
your father now
straight to the point straight to the
Father the brother no let's go on a date
no no because the thing is if you think
about it a woman are valued in Islam in
a high degree and something that has a
value has to be protected because women
are also delicate and can be vulnerable
so in Islam there's protocols in place
number one you speak to the father why
do you speak to the father because
if you have kids you like imagine if you
had a daughter
and somebody and as a non-muslim man we
have something called um
protective jealousy you have that I have
that's not a Muslim thing you have it
the moment if your daughter came and
said I have a boyfriend
yeah let me see that face Jordan give me
that face yeah yes yes I'm trying to say
I feel yeah exactly that is called that
innate disposition which is you have
real protective jealousy who's this boy
what if he's got the wrong intentions
you know the modern day women are going
to be saying it it's my it's my body my
life my choice and also you know
um the the reason for the dating and the
reason for the relationship prior to
marriage you know is to to learn more
about each other to make absolutely sure
that this is the right decision and to
therefore have a better long-term
relationship thereafter marriage so for
you to go straight to the father and
sort of uh bypass all of that also it
insinuates that the father has some sort
of ownership a power over okay yeah and
this these are things that would yeah
feminism yes modern women even not
feminists but you know that I uh I've
spoken to would find that a bit
offensive so how do you yes feel about
that so so people have this assumption
that they are like my body my choice Etc
or they have some sort of Freedom you
don't there are external factors at play
but you have no idea which are playing
your fatherly role which is society peer
pressure
um and many other factors like I'm
reading a book called The Beauty sick
talk about the sickness of beauty
amongst billions of women which is a
pandemic that why should a woman feel
the need to spend two hours doing makeup
or look a certain way or go to clubs and
dress up in a certain manner it's so
cold or she's wearing this much heels
that she has to take her take off a walk
Barefoot uh you know so the point is
this
are you really free is it really I own
my body no you don't everybody is like
you know one of the philosophers said
man is Born Free but in shackles
everywhere so what Islam does Islam
acknowledges certain realities it
doesn't give you a dream he said this is
the reality of the world and it wants to
safeguard the woman yeah and because he
wants a safeguard it doesn't say like my
daughter yeah it's not that I own her
it's I care about her and I want the
best for her so my daughter has two
options I uh That You Don't Own Me or
have trust in the father that loves her
and wants the best for her dream I'm
trying to say because if you think about
it a woman could easily be taken
advantage of and that's the reason why
in the marriage documentary I talk about
what kind of a monster I was do you ever
see men who bypass the girl and go
straight at the dad yeah and the girl
Cuts very little say in it no no see in
Islam there is no forced marriage okay
yes that she has a say in the matter
that's why what the feminists were
fighting 100 years God Islam give the
woman that right 1400 years ago the
right to choose who you want to marry
the right to not adapt your um your
husband's surname yeah the woman were
inherited before a woman would be in
here so for example if my brother is
married and he goes to war and dies I
would inherit his wife that's how it was
wow Islam came to give the rights of
course a woman didn't want to inherit
like if they if a father died should and
there was money she would barely get
anything so in those times you're
looking at standards where it's like a a
man a camel and then a woman that's how
the rights were so Islam came to give
them those rights the feminists were
fighting for it 100 years ago 1400 years
ago so when a man for example is my
daughter is getting to know somebody if
my daughter comes to me and says there
is this guy in University or wherever
and that I have a liking to him and I
would like to get to know for marriage
now I wouldn't be happily go to that man
and say look my daughters come to me
about yourself and I would like you guys
to know each other in a permissible
manner now I'm gonna do some background
checks on you anything that is easily
attained will have no value
simple as that nobody can go and buy a
Bugatti you have to be it's not money no
money is not enough sir you have to
belong to certain members membership
which I'm trying to say the elite is not
for everybody now I'm not trying to
compare a car to a woman because I'm
saying this is something in the mind if
we think about it something valuable but
every everybody is like this like men
and men and women and I think that's a
problem in today's society is people
aren't aware of their value
that's the point the point is Islam has
come to uplift women and say you are
valuable in the sight of God you have
more to offer than your excuse me your
backside
you know and other parts of your body so
that's the reason why Islam is
acknowledged that there's a reality that
we live by which I'm trying to say and
men are visual creatures right that's
why women wear makeup because we fall
for what we see and the reason men lie
is because women fall for what they hear
so Islam is acknowledges and put the
barriers and protocols in place to
protect the woman I speak to a lot of
like for example the Western woman and
they'll say exactly what you said I'm
not owned by and I'm like look dating
this this sexual Liberation has
destroyed women this is what we're
talking about this I can choose no you
are not happy there are studies that I
can quote now that show that women are
less happier being going around one
night stands this destroys a woman you
know I I'm not um obviously I'm not
aware of the
uh the difference I haven't got a sample
from Muslim women and how how they feel
about their scenario but yeah what
you're saying about modern women yes and
them feeling less valuable less less
self-worth yes one of the reasons is
because of how easily attainable they
are now thank you so so if we're looking
at our dating site for example if if
you're on a dating site as a man you
swipe swipe swipe swipe swipe let's say
you match with however many 100 girls
which is very easy to do all of a sudden
if if one girl doesn't put out you just
move on to the next girl and the next
girl and and what that does is it makes
women very much have to uh not all women
obviously there's exceptions and some
women won't bow down at this spot like
the reality in London is the amount of
women the amount of men that women are
sleeping with on average has
dramatically risen I've got I don't need
another date I've just I've seen it yeah
um what is happening is women are
feeling more I guess Under Pressure to
sleep with them man faster to retain his
interest because if you don't somebody
else will and therefore women are
racking up you know figures in the tens
and the 20s 30s 40s exactly they're
having sex with far more men thank you
and because of that they're not able to
I guess emotionally attach the way they
used to because because the less men you
have sex with the more special it is it
is the studies that show that the woman
who is a virgin or had one sexual
partner or her rate of having a
successful marriage 80 the moment it
goes above that it drops to 20 yeah I
heard something about 10 or more and
it's completely different done why
because it's like a knife that's gone
blunt it doesn't do the job anymore
there's no connection you know because
it release oxytocin you know this is
yeah so this is this scientific so what
we're seeing is if somebody wants to buy
a Rolex and someone goes well hold on a
second who are you I'm back on who are
you you want to buy it hold on a second
you don't buy nothing yet yeah so we in
Islam believe a woman is far greater
than any inanimate object so Islam has
sent those protocols down to protect her
heart so that's why we talk about going
to the father and that's why I did when
I met my wife and I spoke to her dad in
a matter of hours
I spoke to a dad immediately and I was
so happy because I've had experiences in
my marriage search where this happens to
them with Muslim girls that I speak the
moment I mentioned the father she's gone
understand it because the Western dating
culture has even indoctrinated the
Muslim woman and Muslim men so to them
that's like weird so why don't you want
to speak to my dad so I said Orthodox
Muslims you would imagine that this
would be the norm right uh no there are
Muslim women who would disappear on me
the moment I would mention can I speak
to your dad or your brother oh that's a
bit soon so it's very confusing yeah for
me because obviously it feels like you
know there's this gray area yes you know
there's there's obviously non-muslims
and then where you are yeah and then
there's people who are somewhere in the
middle who who have been raised Muslim
but
Western values yeah they've been you
know adopted some of those values from I
guess this culture
um so in in terms of how you're meeting
these women to start off with yeah what
is that like how you know because I know
there's a Muslim dating app yeah I don't
we we actually got Undercover on them on
the marriage documentary oh really yes
we do we got on the cover and all of
them on the cover we had um because
there's a is it called
there's a couple and we just look and
say okay is this islamically
um verified in the sense where oh is
this another dating app so we had okay
individuals who were seeking marriage
who went on the cover and we will have
their findings for example yes I'm
getting to know this person okay
um that's fine tell him that your
brother is in a conversation let's see
what he says yeah so they would go and
we would be like record your findings
tell us okay today this happened that
happened so we get all of those and be
like okay are these apps really Islamic
or are they just your normal dating app
just with an Islam on it because the
money that they'd make on it by
marketing uh A specific group of people
is going to be especially when it's
harder for people to meet people exactly
I had personal experiences on there when
I first came to Islam I was I I show my
profile when I first came to something
like nine years ago I had my own profile
so you see me with like you know spiky
hair you know we've seen the pictures
yeah there's more so I made an account
and let me tell you something I share my
personal experiences real life and I was
shocked I was I couldn't what was the
main things that were surprising to you
when I left that lifestyle of partying
girls Girlfriends I hated I was so
disgusted of that so to me
um like coming to Islam I did not I did
not want to witness that again but I saw
it in the Muslim Community okay it was
and I couldn't believe it like it was a
great shock to me I was like like I left
that and I'm now being
offered it and to me ironically because
you're you're the someone who's going
towards that from that background yes
whereas people who maybe has been raised
in it without necessarily choosing it
for their own self yeah
um the the
they would have just been as happy as
out of it and and going down that road
yes there was and and the thing is this
is what came out a great shock to me to
see that Muslim men and Muslim women
um you know having these Western ideas
and values The Way live I wish they come
but it's a story after them but I was
like wow I wasn't expecting that now if
the market is fluctuated men do not care
and that's the issue we're seeing if
everyone said no until you marry me no
do you know what's gonna happen that man
who thinks he can get a side she's
saying the same thing and the other girl
the same same thing he's going to think
well hold on a second
well I have no choice but to marry value
of the woman goes up this is a weird
comparison but it's like if every UFC
fighter I told Dana White we're not
we're not fighting until you pay us more
all of a sudden they get paid more it's
important if two plus two is four you
need everyone to stick together and hold
first the thing that's the problem is
you are saying people just lose those
values yeah which must make it harder
for traditional women to then retain men
so I would meet these Muslim girls for
the intentions of marriage and some of
them would literally
be touchy touchy would in a nutshell
give you know
signs to certain things and to me as a
man I had to know better
because we have this attitude a lot of
men have this if she's behaving like a
hoe I'll treat her like a hoe not in
Islam Islam says Allah says in the Quran
tell the believing men to lower your
gaze meaning I don't care if she's
wearing a bikini mini skirt neck up
fully covered you can't even see the
eyes my job is to look away
now Islam teaches how men to behave and
teaches the value of a woman from a
micro level to a macro level so from a
young age you are told I tell my son
you've seen decent things look away
because do not look at a woman in a
sexually objectified way a woman has
much more to offer than sex she's a
human being she has a soul she has so
much more to offer what the Western
system has done has brought them to a
level where they have nothing to offer
but Beauty and that's the reason why I
sometimes don't blame women because when
they want to be traditional what happens
is people look down on them yeah and
then forces them to look a certain way
there are people who are dying of butt
implants there's a Brazilian woman who
can you imagine a woman are going to the
lengths of dying to look pretty can you
imagine and then they come and say oh
you know but I'm not my body my body
really your body your control no there's
external factors in play that is playing
your fatherly role and pushing you to
certain places that you shouldn't so
that's why we say that the father plays
the Master everyone number one number
two now that's not it there's protocols
in place that's number one you speak to
the father now me if my someone comes to
ask my daughter's hand me I'm gonna give
you some I'm going to electrocute you a
bit because at least you give you some
high voltages have you had any
experiences with fathers when you've
spotted oh yeah 100 where they've put
they've grilled you oh yeah 100 how bad
are we talking like no no not really bad
but like for example I admire that like
the fact that I would you know I'm
interested in your daughter and not to
marry but get to know for marriage
because I don't know yet I can't just
jump into something so when we're
proposing by the way it doesn't mean I
want to marry no it just means I would
like to get to know you for marriage
with your father's permission with a
chaperone so when we're meeting for
example to go out for a dinner her
brother is there maybe sitting there
we're here but he's keeping an eye
because at the end of the day I could
easily you know whatever education so
the fathers were sometimes like he asked
questions they would like I admire that
you know that and I've seen that in in
the documentary when you went and
apologized to the girl who you had the
first relationship yes
you're very respectful at the time yes
and I thought that was a nice look I I
have to because at the end of the day
this is what we're talking about if
every man was forced to do this I
promise you I promise you a woman will
be saved heartache they will not be used
messed around they will not be so broken
that they jump into other relationships
with broken hearts and then what they do
is they end up destroying that man yeah
because they feel the pain that this is
Left Behind exactly it's messed with
them about how they feel about
Manchester exactly and it has a ripple
effect this these things don't leave you
there you carry them onto your marriage
and your future girlfriends or whatever
you want to call them you are impacted
by this so that's the number one
protocol speak to the father number two
she has a dowry so she can ask for money
she can ask for gold she can ask for I
don't know 10 pounds she can ask for
whatever but that's her Islamic right
meaning that if she's going to get
married to me she said to me for example
I would like this much gold and I would
like this much money why that is her
right under protection
because if for example one day I decide
to leave she has that money and that
thing to rely on yeah imagine she's a
millionaire I cannot touch her money
so imagine this I pay for the rent gas
bill electricity Insurance petrol water
you name it she's a millionaire if she
chooses to contribute to the house she
can but she is not obliged to I am the
one that will be paying for everything
even though she might be driving a
Mercedes or a Ferrari so do you see that
Dowry it's again if a man has the wrong
intentions he can speak to the dad but
now when there's money involved where
the woman is saying I would like five
thousand pounds and I would like
um 200 grams of gold argument's sake
yeah for a man who's got bad intentions
he's thinking oh I can go to excuse me
to a yeah and pay whatever yeah so do
you see another second protocol in place
to protect her now number three you have
to do a wedding and you have to announce
the wedding yeah so this these protocols
in place just imagine
just imagine if every single woman
Incorporated this you will not have men
running around cheating messing around
playing Breaking people's hearts the
dynamic of modern day earnings is is
very different to this man provider
woman uh you know a homemaker yes what
about in Islam because you seem to come
from a very traditional Viewpoint of
you're the provider she's the Homemaker
that's how it should be now in Islam a
woman has a right to work she can work
but the problem we're seeing in regular
relationships that I'm aware of is when
a man isn't the The Breadwinner yeah and
the woman is equally earning as much as
him if not more than him for those
traditional roles to be upheld she's
like you think I'm cooking clean for you
when I'm also working the same hours
they're not they're not happy for that
and and not nothing that they should be
but I'm just saying that's the general
attitude so yeah is that a similar
problem in Islam so the cook and clean
the thing in Islam she doesn't have to
we see couples regularly though um
religious are not religious yeah where
the woman is more dominant the woman is
more assertive and we're seeing more and
more interesting problematic women have
a lot more power than they've ever have
in regards to divorces so when you're
talking about a dowry for example this
is a bit similar to what people are
going through with divorces where when a
man knows he's got everything to lose in
the event of a divorce and a woman has
everything to gain which is
unequivocally the way it is yes the
power that's been given to women is to
such an extent now they're abusing it
but at the same time they are suffering
it they are suffering because the thing
is they are initiating divorce is more
80 if they are if they have some sort of
a career it goes to 90 and that's the
reason why in Islam the power of divorce
is
um given to a man so for example this
doesn't mean because if you're Jewish
there's something called the get I heard
that yeah so if you don't get the get
yeah you are not going anywhere you are
State married a person not in Islam in
Islam the one has a right to divorce
yeah so but in Islam the man can say
means I divorced you he has free times
where he can use it so if he says talaq
in an argument okay the divorced but
they make up no problem that's fine
again
they make up again now if the third time
he says talaq that marriage is over so
about legally how does that okay is it
the same as as any other marriage uh
what do you mean by so I was in like
you're about to get you know wrecked in
the courts yes is this happening to
muslimental oh yes 100 oh my gosh there
are women Muslim women where if if the
husband said okay let's legislate by
God's law
they don't want to know God's law now
it's like not under the government oh
David I'm telling you these are women
who are in hijab who read the Quran
every night who pray and when it comes
to this matter they don't give a damn
about no Islam No Quran no Allah they
want the dollar exactly this is this is
this the issue so Muslim men are facing
this I know of people who cannot even
see their kids and this is a major sin
in Islam they cannot see their kids so
this is affecting the Muslim Community
that's the reason why the marriage
documentary The Bitter truth show I
don't know if you see my podcast
yeah so that and I'm working on another
project I've done all this because the
biggest threat now is divorce rates it's
the attack on the family unit so that's
the reason why I've got my attention and
focus on this area there was a woman
that I was watching on uh um on
Instagram so she cooks for her husband
so basically she's a non-muslim woman
she does traditional woman and I've done
a video a couple of like two days ago
and I was praising her and I was saying
basically majority of a lot of you
feminist Muslim women could not be even
her toenail I was praising her why
and she was getting slaughtered by
feminist why can't he cook himself is he
a boy is he a child she was like he goes
to work I love cooking for him look at
the indoctrination that a man who's
going to work can provide they have a
problem this woman may can pack lunch
for him you are out of your mind you're
crazy so to think to me and I know
Muslim women are affected by this and
that's what's understand why other
people's Lifestyles yeah rile people up
so much and it it clearly is evoking
something within them of like
I'm not that yes and therefore let me
attack that because it's making me feel
inferior right now exactly like for me
there's no excuse for anyone to feel the
need to attack someone else's way of way
of life you know and if that is if you
don't want to do that don't do it that's
fine why are you hurl abuse at some
woman who's just I'll be making exactly
I Fella's lunch exactly exactly exactly
you can just imagine this this is
dealing with man hey it's a woman who's
just making a pack lunch for her husband
is being attacked and these are the re
this is the reason why the Western world
is seeing the shift you're saying the
family units under attack and like
mathematically speaking I can't argue
with that you know like people are less
staying together less in marriage lesson
families children are being raised more
than ever with uh single parents which
yeah and a lot of the statistics if you
look into you know single parents God
bless my mother my mother was a single
parent it wasn't her fault and she
couldn't do nothing about it but equally
if you're looking at the statistics of
people in prison yes you know the abuse
it's just her right yes of how much of a
link there is exactly to the luck of a
father exactly but this is why Islam is
so so strict on these matters and now
there is an uprising happening in the
western world and the Muslims are just
saying look we've been saying this for
the past uh 1400 years maybe yeah so
you're talking about like red pill for
example no red pill is another extreme I
will not equate red pill with
yes Islam is that balance Red Bull is
another extreme yeah reaction reaction
yeah feminism we we say to both to hell
with you guys okay
bye-bye you guys are as Extreme as
others yeah red pill yeah I could sleep
with everyone that's nonsense you can't
see whoever you want in Islam yeah you
can't comment I'm a man what are you on
about the capital punishment for a
person who commits adultery uh um if
they're single or married is the same
for a man or a woman it's not a woman
I'm so sorry this modesty thing it's not
just women have to be modest as a man I
have to be modest when I go to holiday
with my wife I I wear a swimsuit in the
sense where I have to cover for my
neighbor to my knee let's talk about
your personal experience again because
um you know a lot of your documentaries
focused on that yes you said you'd watch
something at a young age yes that
destroyed the way you viewed women yes
what was that pornography okay and why
did it destroy the way you view them
because that was a very strong word I
wish I could use a more severe word uh
yeah it you know when there was study
done in America in one University they
showed men half naked women the part of
the brain that lights up for two use you
know screwdriver yeah or a hammer the
part of the brain that lights up for two
years you know what the hell that means
that means when they are looking at this
woman she is not a human being there is
no difference between this and the woman
well that's why they call them sex
objects okay good that is where when I
came to Islam a woman became a human in
front of my eyes
a woman started because Islam you know
the rights of a woman all this kind of
stuff and the way I used to think about
them you know what I used to say and I
find it so disturbing my mom reminds me
I used to tell my mom I never want to
have daughters
I used to tell her she reminds me she
goes remember I've got by the way I've
got three beautiful daughter yeah and
today I look and I go wow you know at
the time of the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him they used to bury girls
alive you know baby daughters because
they were invalued unvalued and they
feared that when they go to war their
daughters will be raped Jesus so they
would say we don't want this dishonor
we'll rather bury them alive in which
period was this was the when Islam first
came to the Arabian Peninsula I feel
like I'm on a bit of a personal Journey
like we all are and especially as a man
who's gone through some of the similar
things you did in regards to the the
clubbing lifestyle and meeting all these
girls and the older I've got the less
I've been
uh watching porn and all and and the
less I did that and the less women I
seen yes the more uh I valued the the
one woman I I would spend time with
thank you and
um as much as you know we might not be
on the same uh you know journey in
regards to religion yeah the things
you're saying to my experience have been
true in in that uh and I feel like that
enables me to have a much deeper
connection with women
um treat them in a in a way that's a lot
less of an object yes and therefore when
you know when you're in a relationship
once you've committed to that frame of
mind of like
and I had this moment where I was like
enough's enough like I don't want to be
that guy
and I I literally you know anyone I was
messaging I just no I can't do this
anymore and and then I was like I only
want to meet one woman at a time yep and
I'm gonna give that my undivided and and
see how that goes yes and immediately
yes immediately it was better yes but
immediately but you need to one thing
you need to understand is that when I
talk about this in my documentary when
you leave that lifestyle it doesn't
leave you you have to reset those
factory settings that's what you said
about the devil's Whispers yes like it
it is still there like you know you
might see a beautiful woman yes or you
might be on your phone and you see a
girl on Instagram or whatever and it
does make you it does flashback 100 like
oh I remember what I used to do with
this moment exactly but not not anymore
yes exactly so the thing is this is
where you fight and we call it the nafs
the inner desire okay you're in a uh you
know intonations you fight that that's
why Allah says in the Quran with
hardship comes East and he repeats the
statement he says we're verily with
hardship comes East and this can be
applied to anything I like that when you
start training for example doing
press-ups for the first time is it hard
or easy exactly it's hard okay does it
become easy exactly good whenever you're
tested with some kind of a trial the
beginning it's crazy it's hard but then
the East follows it's not saying about
um
yes yes yes exactly so the thing is we
need to value and that's the thing we
Allah God Almighty has put these
protocols in place for us to value and
if I didn't go through that because I
was looking to get married for a good
couple of years now imagine in the
Western World sex a woman of sexually
object objectified you can't even look
at your phone we're visual creatures I
don't want to see that yeah I think
these apps have a lot to answer exact
brains of young men I dread the thing
because you've got people like like Ted
Bundy I don't know if you're familiar
yes yeah so here was the serial killer
of women and yes he said that the thing
that sent him down the pornography the
magazine I don't think it's it's fair
for him to put all of his his crimes on
that however he said look I'm telling
you this was one of the things that
triggered me and it does make you wonder
for all these young men who were on Tick
Tock just being blitzed by all these you
know these women's bodies yes because
never in history yes like it's one thing
looking in the magazine it's another
thing where the thousands of millions of
options I I really do wonder what we're
doing to the youth you're destroying
their soul and that's the reason why I
saw myself because I didn't value these
women because imagine what you
desensitized to it yeah look there's
videos like I do sometimes charity
people in certain Muslim TV channels
where we do feel like yeah men Syria Etc
whatever it may be sometimes I see like
people who are like War torns areas lost
the limb Etc there's a point where I
came out with desensitized to it man of
course and and I watched it in my heart
and I was questioning myself I was like
why because when you when you see things
over and over again you're desensitized
and growing up with pawns so easily
accessible and women so it is accessible
for me it got to a point where like you
know it takes more and more for you to
reach the point of satisfaction and it
is like a drug you need more you need
more and more exactly and before you
know it like years have gone by and it's
like [__] hell how do you get to this
point but that's the point they say
there are Muslim men who cannot even get
erection I'm not surprised why because
they are too busy watching pornography
and the brain is stimulated to that
thing that is not real so when they look
at their wife and look at that they're
like oh I didn't I don't expect it to be
like this exactly your wife isn't going
to be able to do the things that you're
like this woman is paid almost like an
athlete to do the most ridiculous things
you can't compare a normal woman let me
tell you something it's as good as me
watching Superman okay let me go to the
10th floor and try it oh you died when
you're watching this stuff no it's true
though it's true it's not because you're
watching me it's not true exactly and
you're like oh let me try that you're
gonna die when you're watching
pornography these people are paid their
special effects God knows what is done
you're seeing an absolute perfection and
then you're like and you meet your wife
first night and you're like Okay so
let's talk about this situation then so
because obviously
um the ideal scenario is you meet a
woman who is a virgin not necessarily
looking you need to understand they're a
woman like men who commit sins and Allah
says in the Quran that those who have in
sexual immorality yeah and men who have
sexuality they are like uh for each
other kind of but that doesn't mean for
example that if a woman who's got a past
she comes to Islam and repents she has
every right to ask for a virgin man
however however when I watched your
podcast yeah the chat show there was a
guy on there yeah a Muslim guy who's
like if she's had anyone near her I
don't want to [__] know her you know
he was very Frank with us and I remember
talking to uh Muhammad hijab he said the
same similar from what I remember I
could be wrong but so it is it is of
some importance of course it is look at
every man it is like for example like
and this thing goes with you it's not a
Muslim Man issue it's a male issue no
man would want to think that another man
had his wife or girlfriend I would not
tell Muslim men to disregard or look
lesser out to their wives if they have
committed a sin yeah because nobody's
perfect yeah and Allah says in the Quran
that you should forgive and have mercy
would you not want God Almighty to be
merciful on you so we need to make sure
that we acknowledge that there should be
forgiveness so the multiple wise
situations an interesting one because
when you talk about it my favorite topic
well you made a really interesting point
on your show and you said men are
genetically built to want to have
multiple wives yes why do you think that
is this is a reality I mean look look if
you look at it for example even the
statistic that showed there's a graph
that shows a woman who has more than one
sexual partner how he has a dramatic
decline but for the man it's not the
same because we are created in a
polygamous nature yeah that's that's how
we are like and I ask yourself this
question as well and hope I don't get
into trouble
you have the right to remain silent
anything you say will be used against
you um uh by whoever you're dating so
the thing is this is a reality so what
Islam does again is what to deal with
reality well you you actually you said
quite an interesting thing on this show
you said women can only bear one child
at a time as they have nine months of
that whereas men you can get a thousand
women pregnant a year they actually said
they actually said I think they said 11
men or 30 men they have if every cell
sperm was to be used they can repopulate
the whole entire Globe the 30 I think
was 30 men yeah because I think each man
has like something million sperm cells
here so the thing is that's a reality if
you look at an evolutionary perspective
it's a reality we are born like that and
that's the reason why I never thought
like that none about that I should have
known this earlier I could have used
this argument but I was getting told
that yeah exactly you should use it so
the thing is this and again which it
goes back to and that's the reason I
named it the bitter truth show why
because women don't like to hear it but
Islam Again by licking me is there to
protect the rights of a woman let me
tell you how now you'll be thinking yeah
how how could sharing your husband be an
advantage to your wife let me tell you
how in Islam God Almighty technologist
man a man is born polygamous by Nature
so therefore Islam allows him to get
married again now when you stop a man
from doing that that man is like I
always say the second law of
Thermodynamics is energy cannot be
created or destroyed so if I get if I
set this on fire it will just evaporate
or turn into something else so the
energy is still it's in a different form
so with a man if you try to get rid of
his polygamous nature it's going to come
out in different forms side chicks
missions and girlfriends so Islam says
no because when a man does this he's
violating the rights of other women by
saying okay you're my side chick meaning
you know when I need you my son says no
you can't do that to another woman she
is a woman you have to go speak to her
dad you have to give her the Maher you
have to marry her you have to honor her
so now Islam says that if a man has a
propensity to do that it has to be done
in the correct manner otherwise men
abuse and say I've got my wife my
mistress here a side chick there a one
night stand there violating other women
so I always say to sisters or females if
you really care about a woman's rights
and I said this in the show you will die
for your sisters he will take a bullet
for your sisters but you will not share
your husband or your boyfriend for your
sisters yeah so the thing is here is if
you genuinely care about the well-being
of another woman and we have for example
there are a lot of homosexuals there are
men who die the younger there are a lot
of men in prisons there are there are
more women than men so we say the
following Islam is a practical a
pragmatic solution that if your husband
is going to do it and I'm talking about
a good man who loves you who protects
you who provides for you who's a lovely
man a good husband and he wants to get
married again which they have the
propensity to do it has to be done in a
correct manner so the other woman is not
violated you you make a lot of jokes in
regards to well I don't know I think
there's a touch of Truth in there where
you're saying like you know he's if
you've got uh like if you want to tell
your wife that you want another wife
good luck you know so [__] you have to
deal with that but unfortunately like
the way it's put a cross to people who
want like me you know just learning
about Islam is almost like she should
just buy the the law of the religion
accept it immediately whereas in reality
you're you're saying it's a lot more
difficult of course and women will fight
oh 100 100 if you say to your wife you
went home yeah night and said you know
what I've met someone in London yeah and
I want to bring her into the family yeah
how is that going okay I would firstly
say come to my funeral
um and make sure you bring some flowers
and pray for me
please do remember me yeah look any
woman just as I say every man is playing
games by Nature if any woman comes to me
and says I'm okay with my husband
getting a second wife I'll be like
whatever well someone said that on your
show he was very like yeah absolutely
listen love it trust me trust me trust
me they're bluffing trust me yeah trust
me I've seen this system listen sister
relax yourself yeah wait until it
happens yes because the thing is now we
believe the prophets wives are the are
like our mothers we call them our
mothers yeah literally yeah so they
there was a time when the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon was with his
companions imagining with your friends
and then he brought some food from his
other wife but he didn't know his other
wife cooked as well so when I shut up
and his wife came she saw that do you
know what she done she smashed the plate
on the floor smash out of anger now did
the prophet Muhammad shouted a screamer
divorce her hit her no all he said was
your mother got upset now the point is
the following if a man is if a man is
going to go down that route you have to
like to say you can't deal with the heat
to get out the kitchen if you do this
when you come home you better see that
knife Matrix yeah so you're gonna have
to deal with the emotions in the UK it
is illegal for you to get a second wife
but you can have a mistress and a
girlfriend the side chicks come
excuse me I can't have a second wife
that I'm gonna honor and respect and
look after and provide for her and treat
you like my wife but I can have
mysterious girlfriend this is nonsense
yeah okay it's nonsense
we have I think you're you're tapping
into something in terms of we have a
very uh accepting Society yes of so many
things that you know the the regular
person yeah there is such a thing with
classes abnormal yes but then certain
things oh well that's not okay because
that's that's to suit men exactly you
know you have to have one rule for all
you can't but that's the thing this is
what we say about the freedom of speech
it's nonsense yeah even the Western
World they don't stick by it because
they know it's not it's not pragmatic it
won't work now let me tell you something
sometimes
um some people come and say to me and go
oh you only became a Muslim because of
the second third full wife and I was
like not really because as a non-muslim
which ones tell me which one's more
easier to do as a Muslim I if I get
married to the first wife I have to
speak to my father protect provide give
her sorry
pay for everything even if she's rich
and then if I get a second wife I have
to do the same and now let's take me as
a non-muslim no rules and regulations
and I can do whatever I like which one's
easier I just have to go on a date and
say I don't have to even pay them thank
you so to me being a Muslim is more
detrimental to my objectives of course
it's sexually motivated but as a
non-muslim man I could either go on
dates multiple three four women Happy
Days no responsibilities do what I want
and you also have to share your
resources with multiple women yes very
hard as a provider that's why it's not
for every man it depends if you have
game if you've got a game and don't have
money you might you might you might you
might you might you might be able to
yeah yeah sign up to my course
Early Bird that's yeah so the thing is
here is that um this is a reality so
Islam says you know what and you see
this with Islam real life problems real
solutions not oh yeah no no listen this
is the solution and the thing is test it
trust me you see a different man I
believe if every woman shared their
husband they'll see a whole different
man when a woman is wearing hijab and a
man is in the process of getting to know
her but can't you know um see her
physically and doesn't know if she is
necessarily what his type is or what he
is looking for yes how how does that
work for a man like because obviously
that's a big thing for men men in the
long term want to feel like they are
attracted to their wives and some women
are more attractive to men than others
some men like bigger women tiny women
whatever yes
um so you know how do you combat that if
it's gone to the stages where you got
serious about each other
um and things have moved on Etc spoken
you can there is an opinion that says
you can see her
without the hijab but difference between
something in the hijab just to be clear
because there's some women who only show
their eyes yes so I saw the hijab the
word hijab is not actually mentioned in
the Quran Yeah so basically it's the the
the head yeah okay but it's it's it
actually means a barrier but it's not
the actual word that's used so imagine
like we're talking about hijab or even
seeing the face you are allowed to see
the face there's but some say oh no you
are allowed to because you have to see
who you married
um and I say this to a lot of girls
actually and I tell them please read the
book Beauty sick and by the way I didn't
write it it's not like I'm saying this
is some awful it's a non-muslim woman
but it's very interesting if every
single woman decided not to wear makeup
because I believe makeup is the one of
the biggest lies out there because
you're missing yourself if every woman
didn't wear makeup
what's gonna happen is number one look
anytime there's high expectations it's
going to be disappointment if you see a
woman she's looking 10 out of 10. yeah
and then you marry and she takes up her
makeup and she becomes minus seven
yeah to you that's gonna be like
now if every woman did not wear makeup
you are seeing what you're getting
simple as that like that's the reality
and if you like her without makeup which
everyone has a liking then imagine how
you would like her if she put the makeup
on but what happens is a woman do it the
opposite way and what happens is they
they wear this makeup it's like somebody
imagine a man pretending to be a
millionaire and then you married when
you find out he's broke yeah I hear you
but if you just was honest about it and
and that woman likes you for who you are
you keep trying to say we put this
Persona we put this facade we put this
face on literally
um a makeup and to me I would always say
that I said this to my wife when I was
getting to know her I would like to see
you without makeup I'm going to be some
baby wipes from you actually yeah so
just uh assist you in your in your
journey and to me I like I like my wife
like to me it's like she's like a 15
with makeup and she when she takes a
makeup off she becomes 14 and a half
yeah so to me like I I found this and I
had to see her without makeup so in
Islam there are certain things that can
be maneuvered in the sense where there
are opinions where even I've I've been
told that she can dress up in a way
where she's covered but it gives you an
idea of the body shape to a certain
extent no I'm not talking about leggings
no there's a certain area where you can
cause and some say even like you can
judge her by her coughs uh do you get it
but in a nutshell it's trusting God what
if a Muslim woman wants to marry a
non-muslim man
it's not permissible and the same for a
Muslim man he is not allowed to marry
mushriks meaning I do worshipers as
Muslim men we are allowed to marry
Jewish woman Christian woman and some
say um they're called magents they were
like
kind of fire worshipers so there's
categories Allah has told us that we can
marry but for both men and women Muslim
men and women they're not allowed to
marry Idol worshipers if a non-muslim
and a Muslim marry let's say in a legal
sense yes does that mean you wouldn't
cluster him as a serious Muslim or if a
Muslim woman marries a non-muslim man
they are committing sexual immorality
there is no marriage it from the get go
the contract is invalid she is not
allowed to marry him she's married to
him she's in constant sexual immorality
she's committed so that you you wouldn't
acknowledge that not me not me God
Almighty says this is not a marriage now
a Muslim man marrying a Christian woman
or a Jewish woman that is a marriage but
some is going to say that she has to be
chased so you cannot marry a non-virgin
Christian or Jewish some say it was the
difference of this question so you you
can do that but for both Muslim men and
Muslim women they are both not allowed
to marry Idol worshipers like let's see
a Hindu we cannot marry Hindu
okay well we can marry like a Muslim man
can marry a Christian or a Jew yeah
because there's a connection between
Christianity yes because we see them as
the people of the book yeah and that's
why for example many Christians who
lived under the Islamic rule they were
happy because they lived they had their
own rules regulations they were
Protected Their churches could not be
harmed they could not be harmed they
were protected why because they're the
people of the book They're closer to us
how do you and your wife solve everyday
problems do you think like because from
what I understand she helps you with
your business a bit as well she was a in
the background of the podcast so she's a
big part of your life she supports me
there's things that could be she can be
uncomfortable about like me speaking
about polygamy certain things I do but
she's a mature woman she's somebody
who's never headed she understands and
supports it and that is fundamental does
she ever pulled you and man uh I don't
think you should say this yes
she's going on a mad one and I just I
just observe it and say okay where she's
coming from as a woman so I understand
we have this back and forth you know but
when us getting to know each other when
we first met the chemistry was just like
it was amazing I couldn't believe it
what do you think it is about you and
her that matches each other so well
specifically We Believe like people the
example of a triangle the further you
away from God Almighty the more problems
you're going to have the closer you get
to God Almighty the closer you get
towards each other so we believe I
believe personally that when you stick
to God's Commandments and regulations
and you listen to what he says
there is nothing but success it's as if
Allah God Almighty has speed you know
bespoke something just specifically
created for you specifically to the
detail and as Muslims we believe that
when I would make a prayer I would ask
for details
details I wanted to look like this and
her hair to be this long and and for
example character this time and I would
not change my wife and as if it's a lot
of women that come and they talk you
cannot be the dust underneath my wife's
feet listen me and my wife have
arguments woof
arguments yeah this is marriage I don't
know what this Romeo Juliet Disneyland
thing that you're watching is absolute
nonsense yeah if you think my mom says
arguments are the salt and peppers of
the relationships that's a great comment
yes because the thing is people have
this perception of yeah Romeo he's going
to run to you we're talking about
sometimes I come home uh throw stuff I'm
going to sleep or whatever so this is
marriage this is our marriages and
people have a false perception and they
have expectations when they get married
they're like I don't expect this to be
like that why because you're watching
too much Hollywood and Bollywood movies
what the hell do you think marriage is
what do you think has been the biggest
challenge you guys have faced as a as a
marriage
biggest challenge I think the early
stages when you get to know each other
you need to understand it's like new
friends you need to know what triggers
them so you're going to have arguments
and these arguments of fights are
healthy because you're getting to know
each other he doesn't like that okay she
doesn't like that I should do that like
for example my wife really appreciates
me taking out the bin I realize that I
could go and buy her whatever but me
taking out the bin is just ah and I've
realized to myself that's what she likes
so I make sure I think we've been out
you know she just genuinely appreciates
that small things not I'm going to go
and buy her this bracelet okay nice no
it's simple small things that they each
other value so we sometimes think in our
head I value this therefore she would
know and that's the problem that we have
we we have this perception and this is
where conflict happens sometimes with
men and women because the other one was
talking about polygamy the reason why
women are so
um riled up about this is because in
their head they think in the following
and this is the problem they're thinking
if I don't like this man I would leave
him and marry someone else or be someone
else so when you or me we talk about a
second wife or a girlfriend or whatever
they think oh he doesn't love me anymore
but to me I knew we know that that
second wife like if they did a lie
detector test on me do you love your
wife yes would you die for her yes take
a bullet for her yes do you want to
second wife yes
I will pass every one of them and so
would you no but like I think having
multiple like obviously multiple women
there's there's
honored on a genetic biological level
like obviously we're programmed to find
more women than one attractive but it's
hard enough keeping one woman happy let
alone bloody three or four I don't know
if I could be bothered meth okay that's
that's the issue though but look check
this out yeah this is why no it's true
let me tell you something it is a
headache yeah but if I was to tell you
if there was no responsibilities would
you like another woman it'll be a yes I
hear what you mean this is on the the
the the mental thing where my brain goes
to like I'm on a beach one of them's
feeding his grapes the other one like if
that was the setup yeah okay good well
you know practice okay very difficult
okay good but the thing the thing that
your desires you would have the innate
propensity to want another woman for
whatever reason now this is where Islam
comes with those protocols because it
says men want this and they want it for
example easy I just want one thing Islam
says you have to provide for us and
you're like oh then it's like and so I
say to women if you don't want to see
the Muslim woman if you don't wear
hospital to get a second wife you know
what you say Tim
okay you're gonna get a second wife I
allow you but you have to provide for
her marry her speak to her father and
he's thinking that is a long bob no I
don't want it now you've no you've
nailed it and yes the thing is is when
there isn't a protocol in place yes you
know uh you could argue that maybe
married men in in Christianity or
another religion maybe more inclined to
do it the the wrong way yes sir they're
just cheap regularly go and find a woman
one night boom God whereas because
there's this protocol in Islam yes it
feels more like a choice and when
something when something is offered to
you
it becomes less desirable in a sense yes
so maybe
um I don't know if this is real or true
or logical but you could argue that
because there is this yeah it might keep
men more honest exactly and that's the
thing we'll discuss about the secret
second wives because why are men men
want to keep a secret but if they are
threatened with not seeing their kids
and all this kind of stuff they have no
choice so we're talking secret second
wives we're trying to communicate to the
females that look men don't want to do
that and it's not that we don't love you
we do not see a the way you look at us
it's not the same way we look at it
we're not a program like you if you
didn't love us you would want another
man good but we are not like you we
could love you and die for you but we
still want another woman I look through
a couple of your posts and I did this
with pearl actually because I find it
interesting to see some of the things
that people post online one interesting
thing was a guy called Tarak uh fata uh
who was an oh yeah anti-muslim writer
who repeatedly had said that you know
it's a negative horrible things about
Islam one of them being yes that Islam
was a cancer in his word yes what made
you want to post about that so I see you
like this year anybody that has harmed
it's not it's just a matter of Islam if
somebody has spread propaganda which has
caused the killing of innocent people
for their propaganda that's the reason
why I confronted Tommy Robinson and the
fire right and all these kind of people
and the scene with Isis members we've
confronted them I have a difference from
them you know we used to go to the
Speaker's Corner with knife with vests
you know we had like Osmond wanted from
the police so we've done it both ways
because both of them are Maniacs who
propagate a lie which comes at the cost
of innocent people why should a young
British woman or a man walk down the
road and be hit by a car or be stabbed
because of someone's propaganda of lies
and the same goes with the far right
when that guy who went to frisbee Park
and run over in his worshipers the words
you say have consequences so to me it's
so brave that people like this who will
hate preachers who are propagating hate
for them to leave this planet Earth it's
the best news and it is eat for me every
single day not to just that day so
whoever it is if they are propagating
harm towards other people whatever it
may be then I believe them leaving this
Earth has brought more peace because
there's a lot of Indians Indian Muslims
being persecuted in India their hijabs
being ripped off by Hindu thugs you know
and this led into Leicester we had to go
with hijab when there was a Israel in
the Hindu these Hindus
yeah so these things I was spinning you
and this is having consequences so
someone like that who's left this Earth
with all the lies and propagation that
they've done I mean it's either all day
every day I don't know if you do that
day actually yeah
so obviously you mentioned Isis and and
look every religion has a minority
section of radical people but you know
in terms of your experience with uh
people like that why do you think uh
extremists
um exist and how and how do how should
they be tackled well to be honest I
think they need to be tackled from us
first so if it's an issue of Muslims
Muslims have to deal with that if it's a
Christian like for example the Ku Klux
Klan they need to deal with it firstly
because at the end we know them best we
know the arguments best from Outsider
it's just like oh you know let's have
some you know these measures in place
anti-radicalization it's not going to
work it's not going to work with these
people you need to speak text that's why
we will confront them we would bring the
Quran where does it say this okay be
quiet you don't know you don't know what
you're talking about so they value the
sacred text and we can only combat them
with the sacred text so that's why we
would have these videos how are they um
able to go down that road if there is
nothing you know that that allows for
that in the in the correct because the
thing is that they take verses out of
context look Tommy Robinson and uh the
Abu Bakr al-baghdadi who is the leader
of Isis they are they are there's no
difference between them because they
both believe that there's a quranic
verse that says Goku and it's an
infidels and I'm like you both there's
no difference because you guys are
reading the damn text in the same way
but there is nowhere in the Quran that
it tells you because that verse is
speaking to a specific context when the
prophet Muhammad peace before when it
came with the message he was being
persecuted just for speaking just by
seeing I believe this is the truth and I
want people to follow it no you're not
allowed to we're going to fight you okay
if you're gonna fight us we're going to
fight you back and we want peace treaty
you value the peace treaty and we're
going to fight you so there's when this
verse is saying that catch them and kill
them wherever you find them it's talking
about the Pagan Arabs at that time
nowhere in the verse does it tell you go
outside and attack innocent non-muslims
because the prophet Muhammad very
clearly said a person who harms a
non-muslim would not smell the fragrance
of paradise so the Mata is clear because
otherwise that means well I'm gonna go
fight my non-muslim family you have to
take so what do you think it is in in
these
um whether it be Christian Islam or any
any religion yeah you know these people
seem to take a book take it out of
context and use it to commit horrible
things to people who are innocent yeah
what do you think the first thing that
comes at the start of that is it just
mentally ill people who oh is there a
reason no they're not mentally or you
need to understand the foreign policy
played a massive role massive role even
the ones who killed Lee Rigby what do
you mean by that we're on policy man
just imagine a specific Nation entering
your land butchering killing innocent
men women and children
imagine we had what was happening now
like Russia Russia attacking the UK you
see innocent British boys and girls
being slaughtered you go and you come
home and your wife has been raped
what do you think that's going to do to
you and you're specifically meaning
which the war the war what's that going
to do to Young British men
why do you think there was this whole
issue when it came to the grooming gangs
British men were [__] the streets
rightly so I don't blame them because
they are seeing their young daughters
being groomed by A specific group of
other people and this happens both ways
you know because like you look like
there's a lot of them white middle-aged
men as well of course but they had a
right because they saw a threat so I do
believe there's some genuine genuine tea
in that sense where
where they genuinely have the concern
but it was mixed with hatred so I
understand so imagine if they are coming
to the streets and believe me if
violence was if they and they used some
sort of violence but believe me if the
far right had weapons they would be
using those weapons so the point is this
every nation fills that and that's the
reason why what they do is they mix that
with this is what they do into our
prophecies in Iraq one million dead half
a million Afghanistan Syria and they've
seen this in in Palestine and they are
watching this and thinking enough is
enough yeah look at what we're going
through and this is where it comes from
Islam doesn't teach us this Islam
doesn't say my teachers is President
Bush and Tony Blair they're not my
teachers my teachers are Prophet
Muhammad I'm not going to look at Bush
and say he's killed innocent people I'm
gonna go run over innocent people this
is perversion in Islam it doesn't tell
you bush is not my teacher I'm not going
to look at Tony Blair and be like oh
he's done that let's do the same back in
Islam it doesn't work like so you're
saying you know naturally two wrongs
don't make a right exactly
um so when you look in the eyes of these
young men who are joining Isis are you
looking in their eyes and feeling anger
frustration what is the feeling for me
to be honest I've had a lot of
interaction with some of them in public
in private well I'll speak to them and
say look what is going through your head
you know I realized they all come from
troubled her households okay literally
I've had personal experience they come
from troubled households troubled in
what we're probably they are troubled
for example in their life okay some
things happened life is not going how it
should be broken up for a girlfriend or
a boyfriend or whatever it may be most
like a lot of them I would talk to they
don't even know the basic principles of
Islam really it's crazy yes they quoted
two of them who were trying to fly to
join Isis they had a book uh Islam for
dummies
they have no damn idea about the
religion they are just young zealous
individuals who want a belonging yeah
and they are seeing okay I'm going to
and they have this a warped idea of yeah
I'm gonna go Jihad and die and what
enough are you talking about do you
think the man is that simply don't know
how to pray tell me how like I will
speak to some of them and I'll say do
you know this I don't think you don't
even know the damn basics of the
religion and you want to fly out and
fight you have they are they are
troubled individuals I realized yeah
they are troubled and they use that and
it's with anyone that has a troubled one
that belonging joined in a gang same
thing yeah I want to join this I want to
join that when you're going through
trauma in life whatever is channeled in
a different way When You're vulnerable
young impressionable you're easily LED
easy we're saying you know there's a lot
of Cults online right now who seem to be
in a similar scenario who are just going
down that road yeah I mean is the word
Jihad actually mentioned in the Quran
yeah there is there is the words Jihad
but it's like not in this sense of like
how they think there is mentioned in
that sense as well for example Allah
says where Allah says and fight with
them with the greater Jihad and what's
the greatest Jihad The Scholar say is
the Quran they say the Quran meaning
fighting in the sense where that the
Quran is the biggest tool what we see is
give us freedom of speech we love
freedom of speech if you allow us to
propagate Islam this whole nation will
come to Islam the Quran is the biggest
Jihad that we have and it's mentioned in
the Quran but there's also physical
meaning of like the biggest weapon for
good is that what you mean you can see
that but there's also offensive Jihad
and says defensive Jihad like every
country has defensive Jihad is if
there's a group of people trying to come
to your land you have a right to fight
them so in that context there's a
physical combat and there's the
offensive combat which is if you're
propagating and spreading Islam now
spreading Islam is different because
what the Crusade has done they would
come and pillage yeah they would kill
everybody okay so in Islam you are
allowed in the Crusaders the Crusaders
you know when they for example were
ransacking you know taken over land Etc
okay yeah Christian spreading
Christianity okay but they were killing
innocent people in Islam when you're
expanding your Empire which Islam
controlled a big portion of the earth
you are not allowed to force people to
accept Islam it is not permissible so if
imagine the Islamic empire takes over
the UK Christians living here they have
a right to abide by their laws they send
an alcohol they can sell alcohol that's
fine but in their vicinity they have the
rights but nobody can come and force
them so all it means is you're living
under the caliphate but you have rights
nobody can come and force it stand down
your throat you can live how you want to
live Etc with certain principles in
place so Islam is not there to go and
say Yes buy the sword it's against
there's a clear verse in the Quran that
says there is no compulsion in religion
you are not allowed to force someone to
accept Islam this is a matter of choice
how is it fair for a knife to Americans
say no you have to this doesn't accept
it well you're never going to actually
believe it and want that then you're
doing it by force right so no exactly
that's the real believer thank you
pretending so therefore what benefit is
that so Islam says it's your choice a
couple of more posts that you made sure
one was about feminism feminism is the
idea that women are free when they serve
their employers but slaves when they
serve their husband and child yes if a
woman was hired by a a woman or a man
she's hired by her boss is a man or a
woman yeah and then the boss said look
here's you get paid 50 pounds an hour by
the way 50 pounds that's quite good
I would like my tea at 10 am I would
like you to make lunch I said that's the
job bro it's a job bro I would like you
to make salmon sandwich with extra
cheese at 12 please
um you've got some work to do here and
there Etc that woman would be embracing
that yes I'm Miss Independent yeah okay
like Beyonce says all the single ladies
yeah all the single ladies yeah okay so
it'll be perfect but the same woman who
when she comes home and I'm talking
about traditional man who pays for the
rent electric gas bill council tax
petrol Insurance water you name it he is
literally paying for everything and he
comes home and says I would just slack
breakfast
I would like some dinner and just a
peace of mind ah misogynist well hold on
a second when you're working for your
employee you're liberated and you're
celebrating but when your husband is
there and by the way your employer can
suck you and don't give a damn about you
your husband is willing to die for you
he's like your personal bodyguard when
the feet breaks in the house you're
gonna wake up oh darling I'll go roll
down and go and fight him off let's see
what you can do okay yeah yeah
it's true so the thing is you would have
to wake your husband and trust me
everyone with this is natural did you
hear that did you hear that of course I
damn heard it yeah let me get a baseball
bat and let me see what's going on yeah
we go naturally and we could die and not
come back yeah we were walking down the
road and somebody said something to your
girlfriend or your wife well she expects
you
if you don't let me tell you something
she would
decide yeah so we have this I'm telling
them
slay the day babe
okay so the thing is we do that and look
at Ukraine look what's happened in
Ukraine what happened to all the
feminism they love the kitchen now even
the ones that are trans I've been
stopped and saying you're a man front
lines please men are dying wow is this
reality we need to understand this this
doesn't mean women don't do anything a
woman for example there was a scholar in
this time he said women are half the
population of this Earth and they give
birth to the other half they are
valuable like we value our wives we
honor them we look after them but the
point is this feminism is indoctricated
them to such a level that as if let me
tell you something what happened in my
post on Instagram so it's a Ramadan
I'm fasting my wife had an appointment
she had to go somewhere she thought she
took the car okay the car that I paid
for insurance that's better everything
yeah by the way yeah my wife told the
car no problem all day every day go I'm
at home by the way I'm looking after the
kids yeah and by the way there's nothing
wrong with this we don't have this false
red pill Narrative of I'm the Macho Man
and no no I changed my daughter's
nappies yes I was at home I was working
I was changing that piece yeah so
um and then and and she goes she was a
bit late so when she was a bit late she
was she wanted to cook a specific dish
which was a roast it would take time so
I've done a post and I said look guys so
the Muslim man because sometimes Muslim
could be a bit rigid so I said listen
guys sometimes when your wife is busy or
what if it may be Etc have patience
don't where's my food no be patient have
mercy on her you know like maybe looking
after the kids what if it may be and I
put this up online oh my God oh my well
I I don't know how on Earth that was
twisted so I'm telling men to be patient
with their wives so we've got the Muslim
feminist woman which I hate the most
guess what they say why are you joking
for why are you not cooking why are you
not helping her and I was thinking what
the hell are you talking about poor wife
she's probably fasting all day and
looking at her it's as if she they did
not even acknowledge that I may have
been working maybe I came back from work
it's as if what you do means zero I
don't understand how you can be a
feminist yeah be a Muslim woman no
that's the point now you can't like the
the very nature of the religion yes is
completely at odds with feminism yes yes
there's some bits where you can say okay
but the point is in a nutshell no so
this must and then she this woman who
made this post by the way she messaged
me often she goes I apologize
um and basically I did this because my
father used to it and I was like look I
understand but how are you painting us
if there's one thing I'm sure we're both
receiving a lot of is is the little
things that people react to what they're
saying yes I don't know anything about
their lives
there is a one tiny little mind you
thing that a video creator will do or
say yes and the people they're in their
own personal [__] is just spewing out
yes and it's like all the the that's why
when I get these like horrible messages
I'm like you got some demons yes you
know you really do need help some of you
[__] out there because it's
brutal and and they don't realize how
they're coming across and that you know
what we're saying isn't really the thing
that's how they're feeling yeah they're
projecting you know what it is they go
through that's why I realized that
anytime they're projecting they have a
certain issue that's gone in their life
absolutely and you've triggered because
in their head what they did is they
automatically envisioned that father who
used to beat the mother up or that
brother or their husband and they're
connecting and thinking that's what he
done he would tell me you know he would
never help me in the kitchen feminists
and no Red Bull but feminists have
destroyed marriages I mean that's the
reason why you have a lot of far-right
individuals who are coming to Islam now
because they're realizing that how
detrimental this is we are on the way of
chaos literally and this has an impact
on our kids traditional people like much
and even if even like as someone who I'm
a very traditional man and as much as I
you know I might not
um share the beliefs in the religious
sense I say the appeal of religion
million percent yes because as men if
you want to try and find a traditional
woman
um you know in the UK especially in the
dating scene good luck you are gonna
need it because possible possible Bros
uh yeah because it it isn't gonna you're
not gonna find that and I am old school
like I'm kinda a man who you know pays
for everything takes the woman Out
treats her like a lady but equally wants
to be respected as the man the bread
yeah but you have to Simple Man look we
we value respect More Than Love
that's how we are we just want respect
at the end of the end there is nothing
wrong like for example me saying I make
the final decisions in my house what
does that mean like if my wife like she
actually made a very good recommendation
like um a couple of days ago and this
doesn't mean I'm gonna be like oh you're
a woman you it doesn't work like that I
listen to her what do you think okay
interesting but the man is the head of
the house I think that's a biological
thing that's simple because there's a
reason why if you ask a woman yeah the
majority of the time you know what do
you want in a man they will say I want
to be bigger than me stronger than me
richer than me smaller than me yeah she
wants someone who can who can be a
leader yeah a man who can protect her
exactly in that role so whether or not
they're aware of it I just think that
that is what women do want exactly but
that's what it is that's why Allah God
Almighty in the Quran has given us this
um protocols in place because at the end
of the day he knows his creation but
modern women also find themselves
fighting that when they receive that so
that's the problem
sudden in attraction if women are
looking forward alpha or something along
those lines they will gravitate towards
that but because Society is is turning
them away from the traditional version
of themselves that would have been
raised 50 60 years ago for example
they're then meeting these men and going
okay I'm attracted to you you're the
kind of man I want but then they're
fighting with them and then they're
belittling him disrespecting him and
fighting with him not not because you
know they're not capable of being those
people of course they are but they're
not they haven't been raised to fit
within that exactly that relationship
style exactly that's what Islam gives
great emphasis because when the family
unit is broken down it has Ripple
effects it causes deliberate attack from
the book 100 I want to say about the
government but there are movements in
place which I don't want to mention here
because I don't want to you know Army
Channel but there are movements in place
they have to destroy their family unit
and the thing is I I used to think far
right were bad when I came across the
far left far right looked I was like man
I love you guys Tommy Robin said like
these people who are crazy the far left
were either in the altercation with them
and Speakers Corner crazy I I understand
what you're saying I think yeah if I was
to go down that conspiracy theorist Road
you know if you want people to be easier
to be controlled the weaker the family
unit is the weaker they are and
strengthen the easier they are to
control 100 yeah it is fundamental and
critical for a child to have the mother
and father in their life it is creative
and all of the more feminized men become
the easier they are to control and the
thing that really convinced me of this
is um you know the without going to say
the word because I don't know what it
does to the YouTube videos these days um
but you know that thing that we all
agreed and not you know not go outside
for however long because there was the
virus
um the way people behaved in fear and
how easily controlled they were yes it
made me go you know 50 years ago no
[__] way yes or you know like my
granddads there's no way they're all
like policing each other the way people
wear it yes that whole the the the
feminization of men like I was on a
train and some guy says to me excuse me
um
you're not wearing a mask and I I had
this [__] pass and I was like I've
got a pass
um and I just turned around and he went
can I see it and I I basically said to
him like
do you want to get [__] knocked out
do you know what I mean like like
immediately I put him back in his box
but I thought like who the [__] do you
think you're talking dude you know and
it made me realize it's like the way
these people
are behaving yeah is a direct result of
um years and years of just the attack on
masculinity yes and I feel like Islam is
one of the few remaining places
where manly men feel uh appreciated and
acknowledged that they exist and not
under Fire exactly and and it should be
like that why should I feel ashamed of
who I am this is how I'm created you
know why should I be ashamed you know
why there's no discussion on toxic
femininity you know toxic masculinity
but what about toxic femininity these
things are not spoken about you know
what we're saying online is whether or
not you agree with this red pill group
or or or the uh the Islamic Creator is
someone who's from the outside looking
into all of these people I understand
why people are gravitating yes because
people are fed up yes we have that night
race of suicide you know and why we
can't open up if we're talking about
divorce rates for example and we're
talking about the way men are treated
legally I guarantee that the link of
male suicide and divorces
most of the homeless people I think
there's studies and they spoke there was
a woman involved there was like they
lost everything that's why we're seeing
that action reaction like if I was to go
to tell my wife look I would not like
you to wear that clothing abuse
and look it's great to talk to someone
like yourself
um in this because I feel like
there's an attack on misogyny and I
understand why like every every action
has an equal and opposite reaction yes
you understand that and at one point
women were not being trapped well they
didn't have the vote they didn't get the
respect that they deserve so feminism
came along yeah but like anything
everything has the potentity to go too
far yes and now we're in the midst of
seeing a a new wave and a lot of a lot
of uh Scholars and intelligent people
are dismissing this as is misogyny oh
they're just misogynist yeah yeah but
you you in order you understand why some
of these people are becoming so powerful
you have to understand of who they're
speaking to and what void is being
filled in yes and that is the the blind
spot that so many people have right now
which is that men don't feel respected
don't feel powerful don't feel heard and
until that's acknowledged and Men gain
more power back in society this is going
to grow and the people who are
conducting these young men are going to
take them in their own Direction exactly
because the power is being given to them
by these men so until the good people at
the top actually
um give them a direction a follow we're
going to keep going down this road of
misogyny
um and it's
unfortunately like that's why men feel
so forgotten exactly I mean even if you
look at breast cancer and prostate
cancer
damn about men what you go through like
look at women shelters in America I
think for there was I don't think
there's one male shelter there's I don't
think there is there's not even one I
think it's a great thing that we have
these these options for women who are in
bad situations yeah I'm not saying we
shouldn't have them I'm simply saying we
cannot for one second act like we have
equality anymore when it's gone too far
the other way and there are so many men
who are just like like left to rot and
at least have some option yes you know
what I mean um but exactly I've got one
more post that I wanted to end on with
you because I really like this one yes
we are a sad generation with happy
pictures
people are not even living for
themselves if if you think about it they
don't even live for themselves when they
go on holiday and take a picture of the
food it's not even for them it's for
others I mean look at this this is the
greatest enslavement that I'm talking
about when people say my body my choice
my you're not your enslaved man the fact
that you're even weddings Etc you are
too busy proving something to other it
might be an X I'm going to show him or
her how I'm living now with my new man
you are still entrapped in he's instill
in your mind so even for the friends we
are too busy living for others that's
why I talk about this issue like for
example we've done a podcast about
um irresponsible social media
personalities Muslim ones yeah we
believe in the evil eye we believe that
people are envious they are jealous and
this will have a harm on you because we
believe in a metaphysical reality yeah
so we believe people can literally harm
you that's why we do not like you see me
I don't talk about my personal life I'm
on holiday here with my wife I bought
this my wife no no one needs to know if
I'm happy if I'm happy that's all like I
don't even give a damn of your opinion I
don't care but people are too busy
living for others and they will show a
glimpse of their lifestyle yeah I swear
to God I was driving in Austin Street
and I saw this woman getting her
boyfriend take a picture she's like and
the picture she got this grumpy face on
I was like I would love to see if I was
your boyfriend or husband I would carry
a recording After Effects yeah to show
your face
how miserable you are in real life yeah
and the thing is what happens is we look
at the life and be like how lucky she is
you have no damn idea about the damn
life you saw one bloody picture of them
smiling you don't know if they are in
each other's necks oh God knows what
they're doing and you're like oh I wish
I had that lifestyle no you would not
want that lifestyle and that's the
problem we're living in social media and
we are capturing moments of people's
happiness and this is irresponsible
Behavior I challenge this should be a
challenge anyone that posts a picture
about how good their marriage is why
don't you show a video of us you guys
fighting arguing why don't you put that
out there oh no why not you are given a
false reality and then people are having
these expectations and when you have
expectations be bound to get
disappointed and that's what it is it's
just and mental health is all because of
this that's why I meant one of the
reasons for sure why mental health is
taking a hit is is people are chasing
the dopamine of this is me being happy
when in reality true happiness isn't
that and we we all say this but very few
people get to actually feel you know
they when when people are looking at
these Instagram posts at these fast cars
and and these guys with all these chicks
or whatever when you've actually lived
it you and you know luckily I have
because I got to realize what a load of
crap it was
um you realize it is just meaningless
rubbish and uh you know when I had a
memory there where you know this
photographing I was in a restaurant once
and I seen this couple and this woman
was dressed amazingly her guy was taking
her there he was basically a
photographer he wasn't actually enjoying
her company having a nice little chat
we're eating dinner we're having a
lovely day he spent Garden was how many
minutes click click click and and she's
posing doing all and I'm literally like
I'm having a chat with a girl I'm on a
date with at that time and I'm like are
you guys going to stop this photography
like I know how to do photography yeah I
mean like how long are you gonna and it
and I realized like this is nothing to
do with you guys enjoying each other's
coming up this is literally so that
everyone who looks at her can go oh
she's special she's at this place let's
all admire her when reality you see him
once the camera went away yes the day it
was as crap as they could be exactly no
chat no nothing you know that's the
thing one of the reasons when I came
came to Islam I saw a video so these
rappers because it was very influenced
by these rappers or these famous people
Etc so I can remember back then I think
it was Birdman Lil Wayne and someone
else here and so there was a video of
them just casually sitting on the back
of a yaw and they looked so bloody bored
they were just at the edge smoking and
just like it was just it wasn't like
your yeah you know I got the
b-i-t-c-h-e-s
it was just them sitting like normal
people and they were just like they just
they weren't even talking to each other
and I thought that's the like flipping
that's the reality and once we see that
and we realize that and it's a lie and
that's why we're seeing there is nothing
you cannot ever find happiness and it
goes back to being content and happy
with your purpose which I found through
Islam to me it's like a connection with
my Creator and pleasing him I don't care
about this person or that person I care
about me proving myself to the one who
created me because he is the only one
that matters I really appreciate the
time of the day last time I still have
your Quran from last time I have to give
it's been in the back of my car
literally let me go and check it I'm
gonna go get it but I really appreciate
it thank you very much for inviting me
I'm speaking with a marriage documentary
I'm gonna give you a sneak peek of
episode two
um yes and you can watch it but don't
cry everyone can watch the uh the
episodes coming up on the documentary on
the Ali dawa YouTube channel and also a
big fan of the bitter Truth uh debate
show that you're putting together I
think that has massive potential by the
way we should we should have some people
call it the
I think people want to hear different
people from different points of view so
if you ever do anything where you need
someone like myself yes I'm always
available to have these open discussions
if you are one day we're going to start
filming because I've got a lot of
episodes already filmed and I'm working
on a marriage documentary filming so
we're going to refilm around the end of
July if you're free just come we'll have
a specific topic yeah yeah as a
non-muslim we went out here I'd love to
come on man especially because of
everything that's happened in the past
and what you guys have done uh you and
Muhammad have been so kind to me
obviously no problem you know it's our
those are open always open and you're
our guest if we do that I'll send you
the topics if you say you know I like
this topic I would like to come amazing
just call me it'll be a pleasure for us
well we'll do that for sure don't forget
I'll put the links in the description
below for Ali's uh Channel if you
haven't already hit that like button
subscribe to the true Jordan YouTube
channel thank you for watching and we
will see you later cheers
all right
[Music]